[Musik]
dass es in kärnten bürokaufmann
trainierter sportler aber das war zu
wenig herausforderung für mich aber
jetzt von der seit 2010 war damit der
polizei und der welt
[Applaus]
hallo ich bin die claudia ich bin
gelernte frisörin aber ganz schnell
gemerkt dass das turnier das wichtige
war und jetzt bin ich seit 15 jahren
beim kolosseum seit 13 jahren hunde für
ein kommunales festgestellt hallo ich
bin 51 geld gelernte industriekauffrau
song ja da hat mir aber die kurzen röcke
christen
jetzt bin ich der dreier beim militär
gegenseitig dazu kommen dann zum
kampfpanzer leopard 2 4 in die computex
anderes mehr vorstellen
[Musik]